be open like what's going to attract
something new into our lives is when we
have created the white space around us
that a new energy could enter most
people they say that they are open you
know well brenda i'm open i'm a liberal
or a briton i'm open i'm at this or i'm
opening up that no no that's not what i
mean what i mean by openness is that
if you think about it like spatially
right like this room what makes this
room open
is the absence of structure so in your
own life sometimes all that structure
that you're trying to build to perfect
things to organize things discipline
things to keep everything great that
structure can also blind you or prevent
and block out more coming in so
sometimes you need to be okay that your
routine doesn't have to be perfect that
your habits don't have to be exact that
what you think needs to happen when you
go into that networking experience
doesn't need to happen the dinner out
with the girls doesn't have to go a
specific way especially in social
situations you structure less lower your
expectation lower your anticipation and
instead go in with a full openness and
trust to that universe a full openness
and trust of faith that something
amazing could come in that you might not
have any control about need motivation
watch the top 10 of believe nation
because i love it hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best brendan brachard and my take
on his top 10 rules of success enjoy
go watch that old movie um was it called
uh serendipity with uh john cusack and i
can't remember the the lady's name in
that movie but it was all about like she
was in this she's gonna trust that
things are gonna come back around and
it's a beautiful thing
so you have to trust that
in your social situations
that things will come into you
be open to that possibility of things
working out here's a simple way to do
that i call it the door frame tag
anytime i walk into a new door in a
social situation that matters to me
right i'm walking in to go meet somebody
new to go to a networking event to go
out with my friends into a bar when i
walk through a door frame i tag i
trigger my mind to say this what's this
going to be like
there's an enthusiasm what's this going
to be like not like i know what i want
and i like no what's this going to be
like people who are like what's this
going to be like have higher curiosity
thus they have higher openness and faith
and trust that something is gonna
something cool is gonna happen that's
gonna draw people into you like that
anticipation that something good around
here is gonna happen that's gonna draw
people to you okay so that openness that
trust that faith whatever you want to
call it rule number two learn to listen
longer the second we have to do is to
learn to listen longer and i know you're
probably like oh yeah yeah yeah brandon
listen i know i got to listen no i know
but people always say you know be a
better listener i say well the essence
of being a better listener
is to listen longer
see respect is really just a
demonstration of listening a little
longer and i think what we have to do is
train on ourselves to be more patient
with people to listen to them without
trying to solve their issue without
trying to input our own story without
trying to figure out the root cause of
what's going on for them i know this as
a man right when i listen to somebody
especially a female and she's she's
upset about something or she's venting
about something or she's complaining
about something or she's just speaking
about something that she's very
frustrated with and it comes at me it's
easy i get i'm like i just want to solve
it i want to stop the noise you know
but that is not a way for me to deepen
my relationships
what we have to do
is allow people to vent at us a little
longer without losing our patients
matter of fact some of my best friends
in the world i tell them the 20-minute
listening challenge when they get home
when their spouse comes up to them and
starts sharing about the day and wants
to talk about a bunch of things i tell
them
just whether that storm for 20 minutes
just listen for 20 minutes
try not to solve anything
try to reflect back what they're saying
or just even be quiet and let them just
go and you know what the funniest thing
is after about 20 minutes almost
everybody runs out of gas
now you say no no no i'm ready my
partner can talk for hours and hours and
hours that might be true but usually
when they first connect with you then
they first see it when they haven't seen
you they just there's like 20 minutes of
stuff they want and at the end of 20
minutes they kind of run out a little
bit they're like oh yeah so so how are
you
and that's when you say oh you know what
it was a really crazy day hey would you
mind if i just uh go get settled
just give them the 20 minutes just if
you when you pull up to your house if
you have to you know just sit in the car
center yourself
then go inside the house and let them
get you for 20 minutes just give them 20
minutes give them 20 you can give them
20 minutes you love them give them 20
minutes then get yourself settled
but if i think we can learn to
allow people more time to talk we start
to find greater connections with people
often we just cut them off often we
interrupt them we tell them what to do
and the worst thing we often do is we
say hey you shouldn't feel that way and
here's why or hey why are you feeling
that way and we try to do some root
cause analysis when really we could just
allow them to express themselves and
they'll find their own way
so listen longer rule number three give
more attention the challenge right now
the disconnects in relationships are
driven by mostly distraction today the
inability for people to look eye to eye
to feel each other to sense each other
to be present in the moment and so what
ends up happening when the relationship
goes astray people start trying to quote
show
love to another person so what do they
do they they go out they buy flowers
they go out and they buy diamonds they
go out and they say hey look honey i
emptied the trash hey look honey i
washed your things hey look honey i ran
your errand for you and they're trying
to say look i did something for you
they're trying to show something a gift
to that person to recreate something to
have that love but all people want to be
shown is attention
and we forget that they don't need
something from you
jesse jackson said a long time ago
people don't want your presence they
want your presence
they don't meaning they don't want your
gifts your stuff they want you
fully engaged fully charged fully
connected with them again if you're
going to improve any relationship all of
the improvement will come from a greater
degree of attention and presence
gifted to that person to that moment
learn to be vitally there and present
with them again learn to have an entire
dinner without looking at your phone can
you do it
learn to have go out for a walk without
bringing your phones go out and do
something together with no phone no
distraction just the two of you to have
a moment together if you don't think you
can do that then you're addicted and you
need to seek digital help right it's
like do not tell me that you can't have
a conversation look i know you think
you're important and we all think we're
really important but let me tell you
there is no person in the world who
cannot learn to have a few hours where
they can be human again
with the people that they love and that
will be the best gift you can ever give
you want your relationships to be fiery
and zesty and spontaneous again then
those things can only happen in a moment
where you're free from other
distractions where you can be with each
other truly experience something i mean
think about it the the best memories you
probably have in all of your
relationships were times when the two of
you were just kind of in a moment
together where you were truly fully
there vibrantly connected in the moment
present together in one way or another
it could be chaos going all around you
but the two of you connected and there
was this feeling of sensors like bam
you know you were there for each other
attention
you have to have the intention to give
extraordinary amounts of attention to
the people that you love
by the way this is so vital because if
you don't have attention think about it
all the ills of relationships come in
when people aren't giving themselves
attention anymore right you can't show
respect to somebody unless you give them
attention you can't pick up on their
nonverbal cues or or guesstimate or feel
or sense or mirror their emotions their
energetic level you don't know if
someone is down or up unless you're
attentive to them so all ills in
relationships begin with giving better
more present and vital attention to the
person you love rule number four
practice positive projection practice
positive projection
what that means is is you should be
assuming the best about your partner and
projecting positive traits and ideas
onto them assume that they are doing
their best assume that they are thinking
of you assume that they are trying to do
things for you assume that at least
they're not trying to cause any harm and
this is a tough one especially if you've
been in a relationship a long time
because you've probably already
discounted me and this video just
because of that piece of advice right
you say no no no brendan you don't
understand my person is always a bastard
you know my person is always trying to
do this to me they're always trying to
do that to me and me look i don't know
your situation that that could be true
but what we do know from relationship
science and it is a science and you can
study communication you can study the
different ways that people connect in
their intimacy and their relationships
and their marriages and you see over and
over and over again that often
one partner says something to their
other partner and that person completely
blows it up in their mind with this big
story about how this other person is you
know trying to control them how this
other person is clearly belittling them
is clearly being condescending is
clearly hurting them but when you look
at the transcripts of their conversation
you see that the partner over here
really just said something very
matter-of-factly and this person who's
offended drew all of their past history
or some negative parts of the couple's
history
into that conversation and projected
that onto what the person said in fact
often in conflicts the person who's the
most angry can't remember what the other
person even said
they can't recall the exact words they
just said well they made me feel this
way
and the reality is that person didn't
say anything that would from a third
party standpoint cue those emotions
would cue that frustration or that anger
but what we all do is we just take
what's upset us in the past we take our
old patterns our old beliefs our old
hurts and our old pains
and we bring them into our relationship
with somebody and especially in a
conflict now we think that somebody's
trying to hurt us we think that
somebody's belittling us when the facts
of what they said aren't that big of a
deal in other words we blow things out
of proportion because of our past not
necessarily what is being said or
displayed right in front of us
so as a rule the best thing i feel that
we can do in our relationships is to
practice
positive projection
just assume that the other person is
there with you
for you and in love with you
think that you know what they just said
they're not trying to defend you they
just might be in a bad place you know
they might be frustrated they might be
tired they might be distracted and don't
get mad at them realize hey you know
what this person is doing the best they
can
i mean imagine if we just project a
little if we gave a little more patience
to those that we loved and we projected
an assumption that they were doing their
best and that they were in love and that
they were with us and that they were
trying i think that if you're in a
relationship that matters a relationship
that's important to you a relationship
you want to stick with you've got to
start assuming better
about your partner you got to give them
credit and the benefit of the doubt
again because you've probably been
projecting all your negative stuff your
own fears your own inadequacies your old
upsets your bad beliefs
into the conversations
and it's tearing you apart
so you gotta figure that one out
practice
positive projection
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five attend acts of
service i think
for those of you who are really
struggling to like meet
high quality people from your
perspective
i can't recommend enough that you get
involved with some local organizations
that are non-profit based
and you start attending more fundraisers
more acts of service and i know some of
you guys i don't i don't have anything i
don't have money to contribute maybe or
i don't have you know i don't know what
i want to do i'm like i don't care
go to a bunch of them and you'll learn
what you like
and i will also say this i know i've
been saying this for years i i beat a
dead drama a little bit here
but when you go to a fundraiser
or you go to a volunteer event
do you know who ghost those
like you go to black tie event like a
fundraiser as an example do you know who
goes there
the most successful high achieving
positive wealthy influential people in
that particular community
people who have something to give and in
their spirit in their heart says i i
play this role in this community where
i'm going to make a difference here
awesome
i mean some of my best friends i've met
throughout the years i met
either doing the work of contribution or
literally on a non-profit board
or at a fundraiser because that striving
community who wants to make a difference
i can't i can't share with them but
here's the thing
whether you go do that or you don't
the people who are closest to you if you
want to make a difference with them if
you want to deepen that relationship
find a way to make a difference together
go do something cool that contributes go
volunteer i think if you really want the
closest friendships imaginable you go
volunteer once a month or once a quarter
you just
you don't wait for you schedule it i
want you to be the friend that schedules
the contribution
be that friend
don't hope that person comes into your
life you're that scheduler
you're that person who sets that up
you're the person that gets them
together because at some point they'll
take it over in all of my greatest
friendship circles
i tend to be the person who initiates it
and we do something and then someone
says i'll do it next time i'm like great
just do that
acts of contribution to god rule number
six just try your best just try
and what i mean by try is try with other
people again
i i watch people talk at lunch they're
not really trying to be engaged they're
not really there they just and it's
great that they're comfortable with
themselves but they've kind of they're
going through the motions
and very few things ever happen amazing
when people are two people are just
going through the motions because our
default going through the motions unless
it's imbued by like challenge or
presence or vibrancy usually our default
is homeostasis of just like
and that is not very attractive okay
that is not something that people's
attention what people get people's
attention is when you put an effort to
listen to them to be with them to be
present with them to change the energy
between the two of you for you to spark
something stop waiting for good energy
to come into your life and start
generating great energy and you'll feel
the difference try with your energy
again right really pay attention to
people be present with them they'll feel
that you're trying and they'll
appreciate it i'm not saying faking
right so it's not authentic and real
don't do it
but you must try more often to show up
as your best self into conversations and
to try and pull out the best of others i
think the most sexy thing in a person
ever is someone who's trying to pull out
the best energy from you right whether
they're trying to pull out the
flirtation of you or pull out the joy of
you or the gratitude of you or that
positive range of emotions from you
that's pretty sexy
so try to bring out the best of others
rule number seven adore people you have
to adore people
if you don't adore the person that you
are with right now you have to re-summon
that up you have to look for the things
in them that will help you do that and
the way to do that give them more
attention
show them more appreciation when they
receive more attention and more
appreciation from you there will there
be an energetic change in the
relationship it will turn more vibrant
more there'll be more pop in it and all
of a sudden you'll start to notice that
person they come a little more alive
around you and it'll be easier to adore
them because you're like oh look i never
even noticed they do these things that's
funny or oh gosh i never noticed they
did all these things for me i have
attention to that now and i appreciate
that now you'll start to adore them more
when you adore the person with you with
more you do things for them you do more
things for them you want to see them
light up you start supporting their
dreams more how are you doing that
because real adoration is getting out of
your own way and asking what is it about
this person's life that i can support
that they love to do because showing
real adoration is showing support
real adoration is not just doting on
somebody with flowers and gifts though
you should do that too it's about
wanting to support their bigger life
goals their bigger dreams when you truly
adore somebody you want so desperately
to see them happy and passionate engaged
living their own fully charged life when
you really adore someone you go out of
your way out of your way to brag about
them in front of them right when they're
there and you're in a social situation
you'll you'll you'll compliment them
you'll you'll brag about them and you'll
make them like if you haven't made your
partner your spouse your lover your
husband your wife blush for a while with
a good compliment in front of other
people what are you doing right i'm
always trying to embarrass my poor lady
you know and but in a positive way
because i'll compliment her in front of
other people and she'll be like i really
appreciate you said that about me
because i want her to feel adored i want
everybody in the community i want
everybody in my life to know how much i
adore my lady so do you have that
intention for yours for the person to
share with does everybody know how much
you adore them are you bragging them up
are you really adoring them personally
and publicly when you do that you'll
notice a different level of engagement
in that relationship too and everything
will change because they will feel
adored appreciated and feel like you're
giving them attention so they'll turn it
around now that they give you
more attention more appreciation more
dorsey adoration and there'll be this
spark and it happens between the two of
you that you never imagined that you
could have that is what it feels like to
live
the charge life rule number eight
support the ones you love literally
today somebody a friend of mine reached
out
about a situation going on in the world
that he wanted to support and was asking
me for support
and it was a cause that i don't know
that much about but i know he loves this
and this is near and dear to his heart
and i can learn from it and so i support
it
i think of all the time like what what
is my wife love oh she loves that you
know that thing she loves design she
loves that show she loves these people
she loves this experience okay okay how
can i serve that up because if you serve
up what other people love or you honor
it respect it cheer it on support it in
some way
the depth of that relationship becomes
tangible and now there's energy there
because they feel
the three things that everybody needs to
feel they feel understood they feel
validated they feel celebrated to live
their own life
so if you can understand other people
if you can validate them if you can
celebrate what they like and what they
love their obsessions
versus making them have to do what you
do
life is so much easier
i'll tell you an example uh years ago
denise and i started working together
and uh we had a podcast at the time hvx
podcast i think we did maybe like 10
20 episodes maybe i can't remember what
it was and it was just super clear
that this was not something that she
loved
and we didn't love doing it really
together the way that we thought we
would it was like
let's call that
so we just ended it
didn't worry about what people thought
didn't worry about the business didn't
worry about he's like oh that's not
something we love doing together let's
not do that
there's things that i love in my life
totally not her jam things that she
loves totally not my jam
but we cheer it on
we support it and it creates that depth
and that closeness of relationship and
if you don't have that with other people
guess what
you don't get to complain
it's your job
to have that difficult conversation it's
your job to bring it up to make a plan
to work through it even if that takes
weeks or years
to shift
your mutual behaviors in that
relationship don't give up on the person
just because they don't get you
because guess what it's not their job to
get you it's not your job to get
but if you want to have a graceful deep
intimate connected relationship it's now
time
what do they love and how can i support
that how can i let them be their thing
let them you know fly their flag be
their weirdness and cheer them on in
whatever way that makes sense because it
makes them happy
what does your spouse your partner or
your co-workers love to do
you know uh in my company's i never am
like you have to be this role i'm like
what do you like to do first always like
what what do you like well i don't like
this i'm gonna do that i'm like oh well
let's try to figure out a plan to get
you more towards that
and that's always been my thing oh you
like that you want to do more of that
okay and that makes a team feel heard
and seen and recognized and if they
complain and they don't like something
then it's like oh can i shift that for
them because that's their vibe
you got to figure that out rule number
nine don't expect others to be like you
i do not expect other people
to think or feel
or experience life
like me
it just isn't there i don't think my
team members should think like me or are
like me i don't think that my spouse is
anything like me she has her own
universe of emotions and feelings are
very different than mine trust me way
different
i we think i think my family my friends
is like there's no
for me
uh demand
that
they
think like me it doesn't mean i don't
get frustrated that we don't have a good
relationship or i don't like their
communication or i don't like something
they said or i feel neglected or hurt we
all have those things the question is
over a period of time
do you have depth and closeness in that
relationship
i promise there's a ton of things
denise my spouse she would say that she
doesn't like about how i think or how i
experience the world
[Music]
and i would say the same about her
but the question isn't do we like
everything that we say the question is
is there depth and closeness and
intimacy in our relationship
and that only happens if enough times
you realize the person is different than
you
different preferences
different hopes different needs
i'm i'm probably needier than my wife is
in terms of like emotional stuff and
just the way i am
and you might be different than your
spouse your friend your dad your mom
someone who raised you
and if you're trying to cram the world
with this expectation that they got to
be think and behave exactly like you
that is where there is a ripping of that
relationship
you had to let other people have their
own life
and the more you try to control their
life the more misery you have
a lot of mental health is letting other
people
live their life
not trying to control everything
you know what mental illness is when you
feel like you must control everything
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is stay in
your job in the relationship i think
it's really important to
stay in your job in a relationship and i
don't mean by your your employment right
you can quit your job but don't quit the
relationship but what's your job in a
relationship it's to love
and it's so easy to forget that because
we get mad at somebody and they didn't
run the task or empty the garbage or
take out the dishes wait i think i got
it backwards but they forgot something
and we get mad at them we forget our job
there is to love
and if you're really going to choose
love over choosing your past or you're
going to choose love over fear or hurt
or pain or choose love or being you know
right
then you're going to start to find
something switches in that relationship
and it's a good thing see most people
aren't choosing love they're choosing
fear most people aren't choosing love
they're choosing hurt and because of
that over and over and over again that
simple choice in the relationship
they're not approaching the relationship
with the intention of love
right if you can approach your
relationship with the intention of love
to say look i'm just going to keep
bringing joy and love and acceptance and
compassion and empathy and vibrancy and
sensuality to this relationship and
you're always doing that more often than
you're bringing negative stuff that
relationship will suddenly start to turn
positive
it will get easier as you change your
intentions to be more geared towards
love that's your job stay in your job in
the relationship to love this person to
make their day to surprise them to care
for them stop asking so much what you're
getting from the relationship and how
they've done you all wrong and start
asking what have you been doing right
what have you been doing to add value
love energy vibrancy sensuality to their
life what have you been doing to love
them ask the question how can you
deliver more love to your partner and to
the world and you might start to
experience what we call
the charged life
well imagine like last night i'm going
on the stage right if i if my identity
says i am a public speaker and it is
important for me to be excellent at this
and then i go on stage and i bomb
what does that say about me as a person
so we've got about 50 years of work in
psychology in the field of psychology
saying do not tie your efforts to your
identity
because
that risk of
disappointment or rejection you know if
the task fails
you shouldn't take that as as a defining
moment in which you say i am a failure
right so that's the risk and that's what
you know psychologists tell us to be
wary of except it turns out that high
performers flipped on its face and go
well actually um
no i do get bothered
if it fails i really get upset about it
i am attached to the process here i i do
care if it turns out well i mean that's
why they obsess about the details that's
why they care about excellence is like
no one obsessed about the details or
cares about excellence unless it means
something to them
and there is a risk the risk is
you over attach
to
the process of the outcome
with your identity so that if the
process or outcome goes bad now you feel
bad about yourself as a human
and now you stop your progress but i
also tell people
there's a balance there
i actually wish more people would attach
some identity
to what they're doing they wouldn't go
through the motions as much i mean
i think what the world needs
less of is half interested parents
who don't have an identity that says you
know what
i'm going to be an excellent parent
i think we have a lot of ceos or
business people or entrepreneurs who
they've never stepped in and said you
know what
i'm a ceo
i own this business i am responsible for
paying the bills i am responsible for
making the money i'm responsible for all
these people's mortgages who work for me
like they i want them to own the
identity of a ceo because most of them
if you ask them about their identity and
their business they're kind of like you
come to find
they're kind of approaching it like
not even hobbyists
it's like if you want to win your
identity has to be tied into that thing
in which you are trying to succeed at
and give to and that takes a lot of guts
to put yourself all in for something but
who's ever contributed something with
tremendous impact without being all into
it i've never seen it so i think the
message of the book you're right i'll
get some flack of
a lot of psychologists say don't don't
tell people to tie more of their
identity or my friends who are buddhists
who say but attachment is the form of
all suffering brennan have you not read
your spiritual attacks i'm like look out
calm down i've hung out with the dalai
lama i'm totally cool
but what i'm trying to tell you is even
the dalai lama
has a connection with himself as a
spiritual leader his identity
is still there that people
you know assume that you know we have to
release ourselves from having any
attachment to something but i'm like i
think
we all want to be present and engaged
fully in the things that we are doing in
our lives
and that's going to require us to say
psychologically you know what i
i
am all in this
that's what i'm about what we found in
our research which surprised me high
performers do not report working on
their strengths
any more than regular people
so that's not what gives them the edge
uh one of the chapters opens up with
this guy he wrote this email really
highly successful guy and he wrote this
emailed me says you know and i'd put him
through all this i put him through
strengthsfinder the burkman the colby
the myers-briggs put them into
everything this was my first coaching
clients ever
i knew everything about him we knew all
his background he did all that he did
all the homework had his peer review you
know his 360 success from work and then
i watched him fail for two years
and he wrote me this email and he said
brendan
stop telling me like what successful
people are like
because we know my strengths i'm not
getting ahead and start telling me what
they do
and that's what this book came out like
what do you need to do
because
and in this email he wrote this which is
where that finding came from he said
this was so good listen this line he
said
as a leader i have to be honest with
myself
that my mission and vision should never
be made to bow down
to my limited
human strengths
i
should have to rise up to my mission or
vision
the strengths aren't the relevant thing
is
the question is what is necessary for me
to develop into
to reach that mission
it's like your strengths are great and
it's like yes of course do your
strengths but that's kind of like
what i tell people is like uh
if
let's imagine you have a bear
and that bear wants to go on top of this
cliff over here
and it's never been on the cliff and he
wants to get that new honey up there
right
telling the bear to focus on the
strengths to go somewhere that's never
gone before and do something that's
never done before is stupid it's like
saying hey you know what just try being
more of a bear all right
if i just you say brent i got this big
new vision i just say just try being
more of lewis
i mean it's a spiritual level that feels
good
but you and i both know you're going to
develop far beyond your comfort zones
and strengths are
typically comfort zones yeah we got to
overcome that and go next level and
develop new skills and overcome certain
fears and all these other things that
are going to help us get to the next
level yeah right yeah yeah the whole
conversation beyond the comfort zone
really requires us to go beyond our
strengths
most people don't have a calendar so
that's problem number one
they're not strategically blocking time
moving towards
the major things they want in their life
they won't say they're going through the
motions but the calendar reveals it like
if i parachute in their life and i open
up their calendar and there's nothing
there they can't possibly say they're
living with purpose or intention and
that sounds so flippant to say but i
can't believe how many people they're
not planning their skill set in
development they're not planning
specific goal attainment on certain
dates so just like their calendar is
completely empty and they're hoping it's
going to happen and it's like you look
at mine it's like it's like
military-esque like planning like i'm
going to hit these goals it's going to
happen big biases i had
that were wrong and you're not gonna
like this one and no one's going to like
it but creativity is not strongly
correlated with high performance
i would have three years ago i would
argue i mean i would have been i would
have been passionately argued against
because i'm a creative yeah this is my
life i write i train i speak that's what
i i would have argued forever i've
designed all the covers of my books yeah
i mean i dork out about design i design
all my web pages i'm i believe that
creativity must give the edge and it
does give an edge in some
certain circumstances for sure
but uh i interviewed a fortune 50 cto
chief technology officer
unbelievably high performing people
their stocks off the roof and but what
he said we go is brendan i'm not a
creative person my team isn't
particularly creative but long-term
success matters just as much about
execution and consistency and showing up
as the creative edge the creative edge
might get you in the game because
remember high performance is long-term
success we're not studying initial
success it's very initial success you
know grit creativity originality all
these things very important the spark
the get you in the game for sure but
even jim rohn said you know motivation
gets in the game habits keep you there
and creativity uh as a habit that the
spark that might be called
original creativity it might only happen
for us every two to three years so
that's not sufficient we got to show up
on monday and tuesday and wednesday
execution is more important as an
example so we talk about the kinds of
creativity that actually matter
but it's not strongly correlated almost
across all industries and i would have
completely argued with that why do you
think people can slip into an obsession
over netflix or whatever or thread count
but they don't do that for something
that could really change their life
feedback
that's interesting it's not what i
expected you to say what do you mean by
that
because you know
buying something or getting pulled into
netflix being obsessed about something
that gives you no feedback is not scary
a real obsession like trying to make an
impact in the world you're getting
feedback
you're trying to make a difference in
somebody's life they're going to tell
you that doesn't resonate with me
brendan
you try to make a difference in a
non-profit you try to change the world
you try to start something like this
and the views come or they don't come
there's feedback and people are
terrified it's one of the four central
fears we all have is rejection
we're terrified like to be rejected and
think about if you really want to make
an impact you're going to get a lot of
judgment you're going to get a lot of
hate and ultimately gonna get rejection
people are gonna like just disagree
people are gonna say that's not good
enough you're gonna say who do you think
you are
and people are so worried
about that
that they stop
and so it's easier things that don't
give you feedback watching netflix don't
give you no feedback it's easy there's
no disappointment there even if you
don't like the show what do you do you
just go to the next show there's no
there's no disappointment there you know
i think trying to make an impact there's
a lot of disappointment and fear and
potential for rejection
so people don't get obsessed about
making a difference and making an impact
because it can hurt people always say
well brandon i lost my motivation i'm
like you didn't lose your motivation you
forgot to show up in the morning look
and think and feel what is it you are
fighting for
see you just show up and sometimes you
check your inbox and you look on social
media or you listen to that podcast or
even you do your workout but you're not
thinking and obsessing what is it i'm
fighting for in my life right now or who
is it i am fighting for because if you
begin your day grounded in what you find
to be purposeful meaningful important
fulfilling
and you say what is it i'm fighting for
why am i showing up why is it necessary
that i deliver with excellence today and
you really emotionally get connected to
something that's the challenge people
are losing their motivation because
they're not emotionally connected to
anything outside of like the outrage on
social media outside of the outrage of
the news or they're losing that fire
inside that wants to build something
create something deliver something
overcome something
so now they're just focused on everybody
else and the real thing is they didn't
lose their motivation they got
distracted two different things
right if you're really connected with
what you are doing and why you were
doing it and who you are doing for
specifically everything changes and
you'll overcome even the distractions
i've written six books now i have been
surrounded by so many critics and so
many judgments you know we have 200
million video views of my views on my
videos online guess what a lot of the
people were haters
but instead of seeing them and getting
angry about it i just see it and it's
like swipe
it doesn't affect me anymore part of
maturity is getting that point where you
can see criticism and see hatred
and not make it your own
not make it about your identity to allow
other people's opinions and judgments to
live out there because they're not going
to go away you need to accept that the
criticisms the judgments the hatred it's
not going away you'll probably only hear
more of it as you grow even as you get
more fame or more people liking you or
more people accepting you or you get
promoted
people ultimately will support you as
you get momentum but people will still
hate you so if you don't deal with it
now if you don't make a switch in your
mind that says ah either i'm going to
limit my exposure to them or i'm going
to change how my i react to them you
will always be slave to other people's
opinions and that is not a life of
freedom that you want to live you got to
let go of those things that upset you
three years ago five years ago 10 years
ago if you're an adult and you're still
angry and pissed about things that
happen to you in high school
you need a therapist and i say that with
all
sincerity and all respect if you're
having mental thoughts that are coming
from a place that are literally based 5
10 20 years ago that you just didn't
deal with yet you need help dealing with
it and you need to get yourself a
meditation practice or a therapist or in
some kind of way that
you're on a consistent basis letting
things go here's what i do every sunday
i go okay what was i pissed about this
last week what really bothered me okay
i gotta let that go
because you can't keep charging into the
next week angry from last week you gotta
let it go you gotta find a clean slate
for yourself so that your your soul can
expand and can be positive and can be
ambitious and motivated and serving the
next week because listen anger after
anger after anger hatred after hatred
after hatred criticism after criticism
after criticism rejection after
rejection after rejection outrage after
outrage after outrage it weighs you down
so you've got to change how much of that
you're taking in and you've got to make
sure every single week you're doing some
kind of like mental detox to let that
stuff go and instead of cultivating the
anger cultivate the gratitude cultivate
the enthusiasm and you can change your
life so what if your parents don't
support you who cares if your team
doesn't support you who cares if your
friends think you're crazy who cares if
nobody in this world sees your dream it
is not your parents or your professors
or your peers or the world's job to
support your dream that's your dream
that dream was sewed into your heart
that dream was given to you to nurture
to protect to fulfill it's not somebody
else's job so if your parents don't like
your idea
you don't have to live your life to
please just your parents if your friends
think you're crazy it's not your job to
make all your friends think that you're
sane if your professors or the people in
your community think oh my gosh you're
just reckless and crazy and stupid
it's not your job to prove that you're
smart to them your job is to fulfill
that heart's desire your job is to
fulfill that part of you that is begging
you and pleading you to follow your
dreams to follow your heart to create
your thing so first and foremost don't
think that is everybody else's job to
support you it's not everybody else's
job to cheer you on to give you money to
invest in you to pat you on the back
every time you walk into your house at
night and you did a good job
it's okay that other people have a
different vision for themselves than you
do just like you don't need to judge
other people because you don't like
their dreams their desires or the way
they live their life or do their nine to
five
then you shouldn't worry if they judge
yours
and that's the first thing i always tell
people is it is not other people's
responsibilities to support you or to
believe in you
and i know that you know when i wrote my
first book
no one believed me i quit my nine to
five job and everyone goes you're so
crazy to quit this job
who are you to be a writer you're a dumb
kid it's true who was i to be a writer
but i didn't worry what other people
thought or if their judgment was
approval for me to go ahead
in my heart i knew i wanted to write i
wanted to create and that desire was
what i listened to
not other people's judgments or opinions
and remember most other people's
opinions are completely uninformed
opinions about you so i say first and
foremost own your dream it's yours your
job to cultivate it's okay if nobody
else believes you the other thing that
fascinates me that you've written about
high performers
is this
strive for perfection where high
performance can often be hard on
themselves
and and i'd love to hear your
perspective on this it's this difference
between
the pressure that we place on ourselves
versus complacency yeah because i think
right now we're hearing a bit of both
out there on social media and everywhere
a lot of people are confused it's like
do i really go hard on myself and am i
really disciplined and am i really harsh
to myself well actually do i just let it
go and just let it flow and let it
happen and you know i want to hear what
your research on the high performer said
yeah they gave me perfection versus
progress yeah there's there's no
question they're more into progress than
perfection there's no question there's
like zero question that
they are working on the things that move
the needle in their life so they're
focused on the
the the things that matter most so
they're good at wheeling out
distractions
but
you know what i was telling people was
like if you think you're a perfectionist
you're probably lying and and the reason
that is and that people hate when i say
that but if you look it up in the book
in the dictionary it's like perfection
like if you actually look at perfection
or to perfect it comes from that root
word to perfect
to perfect does not mean it's done
to perfect means
like
two things happen in in that connotation
of true perfect first it has to be an
iteration or a start it has to be done
in like first draft
to perfect it means take it from being
done being released being out there
being com you know where you feel like
it's a start
and then to perfect it to keep working
on it to keep iterating on it
and what perfection i what
perfectionists always say here's what
they really say
well
i haven't started yet because i'm a
perfectionist and i'm only going to do
it if i can get it completely right
no you're lying there's a difference
between want there's a difference
between perfecting and being fearful yes
and what most perfectionists are is
they're scared
they're scared to start and scared not
to get it right so they don't even begin
yeah a real perfectionist is so in
friggin motion
they are they're perfecting they're
beating up they're iterating they're
dialing it in and they are active at it
to perfect requires an active
improvement
and most people who say that perfections
are actually dead stop fear people are
scared to start their big dreams because
they fear
their dream won't work out
they think oh well brennan you know what
if i do all that work and you know on
the other side of things you know the
grass isn't greener i went through all
that work and i put my heart and i put
my soul into it and it doesn't work and
i mean how do i feel about myself and
you know i have responsibilities in my
family or to other people and and i do
all the things that doesn't turn out and
they're so scared it's not going to work
and that's why i say my friend get
yourself a mentor get yourself a plan
get yourself
in the proximity of someone who's done
it before so they can guide you so they
can cheer you on
of course you're going to fear it's not
going to work out if you can't see where
it's going to go if you can't see how
other people have gotten there so read
their biographies study their process
read their books take their courses
engage their material ask the questions
there's so many i mean the world is full
of mentors that you can access with a
direct message now
use that
ask the questions there's seminars
there's live events there's online
courses everywhere available for you
there's a bajillion ted talks there's a
bajillion biographies why aren't you
consuming more of those to understand
people's emotional journey to understand
their process to understand the big
decisions that they made to understand
their regrets to understand their
lessons of course you're scared to start
if you haven't seen the illuminated
journey of others
but once you see the map they took once
you hear their process once you learn
the mistakes they made now that
emboldens you your mind goes oh i got a
little more clarity here with more
clarity comes more confidence with more
clarity confidence momentum you'll go
after that my dream my friend no matter
how small you start start something that
matters why are you so good at
relationships like what are a few of the
things that make you bond with people as
quickly as you do
um
i always come back there must be an
intention there so the intention where
the intention come from the intention
for me came from
you know
when i was
on my death bed
and
in you know two times in my life i
thought i was gonna die um and the one
that gave me the greatest gift was the
did i love part of did i live that i
loved i matter
i saw scenes
of my life
when i thought i was gonna die i saw
scenes of my life when i was surrounded
by the people that i loved
and my instant feeling was
i'm gonna miss them
and they're gonna miss me and i'm dying
and that's so sad
and that was as important as did i live
my life or did i make a difference it
was like i'm so sad and i got that as a
19 year old kid like a breakup a
relationship sent me into
suicide
that realization was like oh my god at
the end all you're going to wonder is
about your family and your friends and
people you loved and all they're going
to miss you so i got
early that that one of the objectives of
this game has to be deep relationships
high performers they kind of know the
service they want to bring to the world
that's what's like jay's going to smash
this
because i mean you were so humble you're
like i've only been doing this x amount
of time brendan
but you already knew you want to make
wisdom go viral and you knew what was
true to you
you knew the type of purpose you wanted
to make and you were and you're still
seeking that out and clarifying like we
all are
but high performers know the service
they want to give to the world
and they don't know it exactly or
perfectly but
they're intentionally moving towards
that and so for those who are like i
don't know if i have clarity i'm like
okay get cleared about yourself a little
more yeah about how you want to treat
people and be with people about what you
need to develop
and how you want to give or serve
and if you focus on that like every day
every week you're conscious of those
four things one day you're just so much
more confident and clear you need to
learn
versus judge
when it comes to your behaviors and your
results in life
so here's what i love you to do start a
sunday review and every sunday all i
want you to do is sit down and really
evaluate how you showed up this last
week i mean how did you really show up
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
what situations did you do good in what
situations could have done better in
what did you learn about yourself
and use that review session not to beat
yourself up not to say i wish i woulda
coulda not to be mad at yourself not to
stir self-talk that's filled with safe
hate self-hatred but rather to say okay
what did i really learn about who i am
and what i prefer in life what did i
really learn about what i like
what did i learn about the best of me
and what did i learn about the go
through the motions me where did i feel
down what do i feel confident and start
experimenting with how you view yourself
by better doing a job of reviewing your
week
i think one reason people don't have is
confident like mentality as they should
is because they're just barreling
through week after week after week after
week kind of blind and dumb to how far
they've grown
but if you can instead of judging
yourself and like i sucked yesterday you
can like every week have a real
self-evaluation session how did i do
what did i learn
and in that personal development where
you can look at yourself objectively
without judging without being mad
without giving it negative labels and
just go how how did i do what did i
learn what could have done better oh i
could have done this and just kind of
observe how you're going through your
life
and then tell yourself okay next time
i'll do this and next time i'll do this
and next time i'll do that that's a
learning mentality versus a judgment
mentality a judgment mentality was i was
an idiot i was stupid i didn't like
myself i look stupid people are gonna
make fun of me they're gonna hate me
that judgment self-talk is why you have
so little self-confidence
because most people spend most their
time
criticizing themselves their self-talk
is so negative
instead of learning oriented
as soon as you switch from like a
negative standpoint to a learning
standpoint disappointment goes away
embarrassment goes away
self-hatred goes away and you start just
learning your way into the new and
strongest you all i want to do and what
i realized early on from reading
personal development books is your life
creates a ripple
and so i'm always trying to
realize that maybe i can make somebody
smile today and
now when they go home they're nice to
the kid
that's a real thing
and so i treat people with that
recognition because i don't know if you
ever sometimes when someone treats you
bad
it really does mess up the rest of your
day
and i had people beat me when i was a
kid i got in fights when i was a kid i
was in martial arts most of my life so i
i've just had like super violent things
happen in my life i've had
a lot of drama
um with relationships early in my life
and i'm talking like pre-20s
and
i just
wanted to be
the positive ripple transitions takes
place in
the chapter of generate energy and also
maybe it's in productivity too uh and it
has this converse it's just a
conversation
that
if you're go go go go all the time
you're depleting energy all day and you
don't know it and lots of people think
to get more energy or more productive
they have to radically change your life
i'd better work out an extra 60 minutes
in the morning it's like actually let me
teach you the mastery of managing
transitions when you go from one
activity
to another i want to teach you the
simple thing and that is release tension
set intention
very simple let me give you an example
because it really helps if you're doing
email
and you know that that takes one part of
you your your psyche and brain to do a
lot of email and now you're gonna go
create that keynote or that powerpoint
presentation that you want to be flowing
and visual and beautiful very different
things what most people do is they'll do
their email and then they'll work a
little on the presentation then the
notification come over here and then go
back to the email and then they're
multitasking yes and they're wrecking
not only their measurable creativity but
their long-term performance and so what
you have to do is
when you finish the email stop it
okay maybe go get some water come back
or whatever even if you don't all we do
push away from your chair for a minute
close your eyes
repeat the word release
with
the goal of releasing tension in your
body
and repeat the word released yourself
several times over and over like a
mantra
okay just three p it could be 60 seconds
it could be one minute can be two
minutes whatever you want to do
just do it until you feel like your body
and your mind release a little bit
then
before you open your eyes set an
intention say okay
brendan you're going to work on this
keynote now your intention is to make
something that grabs them right at the
beginning and then make it really move
fast and make it
make it visual and make sure that it
builds emotionally throughout the thing
so when you make a call to action at the
end bam
and then open my eyes now work on
presentation i'm clean and free from the
previous activity yes
and people will feel an unbelievable
amount of energetic just power come back
from there i interviewed or i've worked
with
uh a major founder in the startup
silicon valley world flew me down at 3
00 am and
i guess it was around after midnight on
private jet it was just great he was
having a lot of trouble just exhausted
literally depleted um you know this
person is incredibly well valued at his
company lots of employees everyone knows
who the person would be
but miserable
just go go go go go and i said what's go
and one of his major things was he was
wrecking his relationship with his wife
and his children
because not because he was
maybe just overworking he would just
carry a lot of the work into his house
yep so once i say i want you to pull up
to your house
after the day of working don't get out
of the car
pull up the pull up the house
just close your eyes repeat the mantra
release yourself maybe five minutes
and then before you open your eyes set
the intention how do you want to be with
your wife when you enter
the house
what kind of dad do you want to be to
your daughter
just set that intention
open up your eyes now go in as a
different man
and it changed his life his email to me
is in the
it's fantastic it just works that means
just release tension yep set intention
it's just your transitions are where
most people is bleeding out their energy
and they don't know and if we can just
get you four or five times of transition
really well throughout the day you
finish your day like i feel amazing yes
and we didn't we didn't caffeinate you
we didn't do anything we just changed
how you approach your work high
performers develop
influence
more than those around them
it's not because they're cool it's not i
mean look at me
i'm not getting ahead of my cool factor
here lately i just got these these new
nikes
i walk in the stores like what's your
newest shoe they're like these ones i'm
like i need that and they're like wow
i'm like because lewis has sneaks man
i i wear suits or like i'm either on
stage in a suit or or at my you know
studio kind of like you know kind of
formal too sure sure um i was like man i
gotta get some sneak stuff
i said give me your newest sneak so i'm
not getting a head on the cool i don't
develop influence because i'm cool it's
not your personality it gives you
influence it's how you treat other
people and specifically the way that
people high performers gain influence
is is this way too much
get it
how do you develop here's how you here's
how you develop influence
if you really want high level of
influence
obviously you got to do all the basics
treat people nice be kind and in the
book what i do is with each habit i say
here's the basics
but then i go here's what the needle
mover practices are
the highest performing influencers what
they're doing often they don't know
they're doing it by the way
the first thing they're doing is they're
teaching people how to think
a lot of your show
gained influence i really believe
because you're really good at teaching
people how to think thank you you're
shaping their mindset
but high performers are really doing it
uh explicitly and you do this too where
you say
here's how to think about that guys or
high-performing leaders tell their team
here's how we should be thinking about
ourselves here's how we should be
thinking about the competition here's
how we think about the future of the
company they're saying it they're
explicit more often here's how to think
i mean the the the what is it the
seventh most read book in the history of
the world
is think and grow rich
crazy it became that way because he
taught people how to think about money
we have to tell our audience how to
think about things
the second thing they're doing is
they're challenging people
and they're challenging the specific way
if you listen to great orators great
speaker
the pros when i know i'm like oh this
person studied speech before
is they challenge the audience in three
ways they challenge the audience's
character
then they challenge the audience's
connections their relationships then
they challenge the audience's
contributions what they're giving
you hit all three of those the audience
is like i have to listen to her i have
to listen to him because not only are
they shaping how i should be thinking
because maybe i was thinking wrong
but now they're pushing me cause you
know it's just like a great coach the
greatest coaches
they're not just saying throw the ball
better they're like louis you're a
better man than that come on man
they're saying look you're treating your
team like crap
they look look you're not contributing
the team here that's a different
challenge than just throw the ball
faster or catch the you know
so
i studied that from them but those are
the primary things and the third thing
of course is role modeling
you know standing i mean if i'm the
bring the joy guy or i'm the honor the
struggle guy or i'm the high performance
guy and i'm off my game
people are going to know that yeah
so that's i'm always trying to role
model what i do which is hard when
you're talking about high performance
because everyone thinks well don't you
have a bad day i'm like dude
i i have bad moments i would say bad
days because yeah i don't want to go to
bed and feel like the day was bad
um
but at the same time i think that's why
they're developing influence i get up in
the morning i drink 20 ounces of water
i do 20 minutes of mobility movement and
stretching every morning
then i read for 20 minutes something
positive for me it's almost always a
self-help book or a leadership book
almost always sometimes a business book
almost all with self-help and leadership
read that book then
i
go and i sit down
with my high performance planner
my green tea i fill out the day
right i look at the blocks of time that
are already scheduled
and then what i do is my second
visualization which is i look at the
major blocks of time that have been
scheduled just like this this morning
and i close my eyes
and i think
how do i do that thing with excellence
what would make that thing
special
so this morning before i got here
when i thought about this because
there's my high performance planner
impact theory tom bill you oh yes three
exclamation points literally so i looked
at the schedule it closed my eyes and i
thought okay
what do i want to communicate on tom's
show how do i want that to feel
what do i want to communicate so i
literally close my eyes and i visualize
those blocks of time and how would i do
them well
that's a superpower most people write
their day out and they just go about the
day and then they sometimes they come
back to the plan and they go oh my god i
didn't even do it
because i sit there and i think about
how do i do that well
that's a game changer in terms of
clarity what is that habit that you take
on on a daily or monthly basis with
habit with clarity what do you think
about you're like every morning what am
i clear about or yeah you know how do
you apply that habit to your life uh i
apply in a couple ways
first for me
every situation i go into
i'm consistently asking like what what's
the feeling i want to
have here if you ever see me teach it's
often i would say bring the joy so i
have joy triggers that i've set up in my
mind that makes me more intentional
about things so for example a door frame
trigger whenever i walk through a door i
say bring the joy
so when i walk through that door right
there it's like bring the joy into this
room
it's just it's just a mental trigger
that i've set up for myself every
morning in the shower i ask myself three
questions
and not that i shower every morning
the first question i say what can i be
excited about
so
today
forces me to be clear about what's going
to draw joy enthusiasm for me number two
i say
what might trip me up today
because usually i know what's going on
today i'm like what what might mess me
up what my where might i perform well
what might bother me and number three i
say what can i do to surprise somebody
today
to give a gift of appreciation or
acknowledgement today and so i think
through that in the morning so i think
that helps me begin my day pretty clear
um then when i sit down before i do work
i literally look at my calendar of the
day this morning
and i look at whatever's going on the
day and i think about it for 20 minutes
it's one of my 20-minute routines in the
morning i literally
think about my calendar
for 20 minutes a day
people think that's crazy
but what i'm thinking through when i'm
looking account i'm like okay i'm going
to have that call
what do i want to happen on that call
you know what's my intention for that
call what's my goal for that call what's
the feeling for that call how do i want
to end that call
you know i'm gonna have that time with
louis like how do i want to be there and
and how can i make sure i enjoy it
because it's a big deal you know i love
your show i want to do a good job i want
to share something good for the people
even though i have no idea what you're
going to ask
right and this i just i want to be
present for that and and make sure i i'm
i'm really there even though maybe i
have a head cold today you know it's
like it's like just thinking through it
i think
that helps me it keeps me asking
questions every sunday i do a life
arenas assessment that just means i
think there's 10 areas of our life
and i score myself in them
and this is about my 11th year of doing
this wow so each area of my life you
know from
from emotional quality to happiness to
relationships to time to hobby etc i
just give myself a score of one to ten
and one means i suck
and i i was horrible in the previous
week on that ten means i did a good job
and then i asked how can i do better
it's my sunday routine yeah and it just
keeps me clear
and it's not like i don't
sometimes like everyone else you know
wonder what's going on or what i'm doing
but
those habits
those were my habits
you have to establish your own for
seeking clarity but when you have them
you weaponize your life high performers
are not dissatisfied strivers
they're not they're happy high
performers are happier than their peers
we all believe that to get the top it's
gonna be lonely at the top and we all
believe you have to grind and kill
yourself to get there yeah and that's
completely wrong and the data proves it
worldwide
which is i think just overcoming a lot
of people's biases about how you work
today because right now
especially today like you know grind on
social media is so popular or hustle or
hustle and it's by the way none of the
top 15 percent of high performers
worldwide
identify with those words
they literally don't we asked them we
did a whole keyword analysis yep this
was actually pretty cool and high
performers explicitly say these these
are the three driving feelings if we
said there was a high performance state
it's driven from these three things
number one full engagement yes number
two
joy yes
and number three confidence yes that's
what they relate with okay that's where
it's coming from it's a joyous journey
not a dissatisfied one and this i had
this conversation in the book um
because
uh i kind of maybe
frame it this way each of these chapters
opens with a vignette
of somebody i worked with or a situation
that i was in that demonstrated high
performance in this particular situation
i'm walking on stage
thousands of people
after a very famous musician was out
there and was telling the audience that
that person's secret to success remember
thousands of people yes their secret to
that person their whole speech their
secret to success was
never settle
never settle nothing is enough never
settle and never be satisfied never be
satisfied always demand more and i'm
like oh
my second slide which is going to be on
jumbotrons in like 80 point text
was strive satisfied
i'm like oh i'm gonna have to dispel
this for all these thousands of people i
was totally freaked out yeah
and but what i had to explain to people
was not only the data
but it's this
uh
if you're never satisfied
i mean
is it true that life is precious
if it's true that life is precious and
you could be gone tomorrow do you really
want to think you know what i just never
felt fulfilled
i never allowed myself to have a moment
of credit
i never allowed myself to have a moment
of peace i never allowed myself to look
at that and say good job
that's not the way to live life right i
think just at a spiritual level it's a
bad move and this book doesn't really go
in a lot of that it's more about the
science and the heart stuff
but i think it's really important that
people realize
your job is to strive satisfied and if
you strive satisfied more often
you will be more of a high performer and
if you never give yourself credit you're
always beating up on yourself you're
always thinking that's not perfect
enough
then what's going to happen dissatisfied
people burn out and they quit
more often
than satisfied strivers so take joy in
the moment
engage with what you're doing
allow credit and satisfaction enjoy to
come in you can always be improving of
course but be proving be improving
joyfully yes and if you're improving
joyfully then you're learning you feel
curious you feel engaged the joy is
there you'll get more confident because
you're like i'm gonna learn through this
anyway this would be great
because you know this
this thing is all over social media
right now like
you know grind work whatever and i'm
like
it's just it's popular and i see why
that happens and i see why it's catchy
it's just not scientifically valid yeah
what does that rebuilding process look
like for somebody who's trapped in
depression and suicidal thoughts yeah um
i've been there a lot
in my life uh especially
before my car accident my teenage years
than the first woman i ever loved we had
a
big breakup
and that breakup sent me down in
depression and suicidal planning
and
it's tough to dispense advice to people
other than get help and i'll share why
because that time in my life i had so
many people coming up to me
you know my friends would come into my
dorm room
let's go do something and you just
there's just the hope is lost
and what people i think make the mistake
of trying to do is hype people up
everything's gonna be okay you're gonna
be great
and what people need who are suicidal is
serious psychological intervention they
need to seek support and help and
outside of that
when they do get that support the first
thing a great therapist is going to do
outside of the emotional reflection work
of why are you here and what has caused
this sort of pattern for you they're
going to get you starting to get some
momentum
the most important thing is when you are
super down
outside of finding that emotional
reasoning for where you are
is to start getting momentum because
with momentum comes hope with momentum
comes motivation with momentum
comes
you know that feeling that there's a
reason for tomorrow
and so it's as simple as just saying
okay what are three things i'm going to
do today
and
i don't mean that like a lot of personal
development guys would say like what are
your three big goals for the day
i'm like dude sometimes that first goal
is shh i'm gonna shower today
i'm really in shower today
uh
i'm gonna walk to the library
and come home
and that's all they got
like literally that's all they got
and you gotta honor that struggle
when you're in that place like know that
where you're at it is okay that you're
there
and now you're gonna need help and now
you're gonna have to set up some daily
practices just every day win a little
bit
not like win your dreams not like crush
through goals not like be badass not
like no just momentum man
you know most of the guys i've dealt
with
in that position who were suicidal
outside of their therapeutic work i said
the most important thing you can do is
win the morning
just win the morning man i think that's
true for all of us even high performers
like i if i don't have my morning
routine game i i feel you know out of
sorts um so i think it's true for
everybody you got to own your morning
you got to win it because that starts
and sets up everything else i know you
believe that as well like people need
that discipline those routines
that will help the rest of their day go
better
um
and
i don't want to ever be flippant with
the advice to people who are dealing
with that situation outside of get some
help
get some momentum and be okay if that
momentum is really small
because it will build trust that that
momentum builds and trust those
gloomy and bad dark days
trust that those are
going to be there
they'll get less and less and less as
you learn how to cope
but they're going to be there
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want even more brendan burchard check
out the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there double down on
your goodness
you want to have an exceptional and
incredible 20 20 you want to find
purposes here double down on your
goodness
adopt the role model mindset and say how
can i be a role model